où
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
[Musique]
où
je suis pas un franc du but j'ai des
choses à prendre cordon bleu père dodu
possède un goût de légende trottinait
des cas locaux sur le quai donc je
dérape sur ce sont quatre lacs boîte
vient donc acheté tous mes produits
sucrés les commandes étaient statut
falaise averti qu une famine en se
rassurant bon il a dix bébés jeu
avec la nouvelle
puis juste ici plus tu fais lapider pas
traîné c'est d'ailleurs les articles
sont bons oui on bat pour du clic on
fait de la prévention joue pas du fric
aulas sur son kit séduit chroniqueur
patrick chapitre atomique et placement
parce que j'ai gagné
[Musique]
merci pourquoi j'ai l'air
place
et m
parce que j'aime
je sais pas
m
g
avec mac os x passé chez sosh je prépare
ma purée victor jetant de rallumer tel
week aux échecs je vois les poteaux je
suis couvre à peine les ficelles avec
moins d'eau douce mais bien d'un bateau
tu garderas
[Musique]
montmagny choksy action pour nettoyer
psyché pas nager j'suis un cancer je
viendrai forme en vivant du panache et
[Musique]
c'est parfois geiser
là
ce que j'ai
comprenez
m
[Musique]
maxence je crois qu'on a un problème toi
qu'est ce qui est le cas en fait
néanmoins vu les gens se désabonnent à
non c'est vrai tu auras qu'on a fait une
connerie
[Musique]
car j'ai perdu mes yeux
on trouvait même temps je
là
m
je n'ai pas
plat
gfr
[Musique]
c'est trop tard
mais je suis là
[Musique]